tengo aquí el número 324 el cual podemos
representarlo como pongamos un 3 en el
lugar de las centenas esto es
en atenas
tengo un 2 en el lugar de las decenas
por lo que puedo decir más 2
en más
y luego tengo un 4 en el lugar de las
unidades por lo que puedo decir más
si quieres pensar en cómo se ve eso
puedes ver todos estos bloques de aquí
tres grupos de centenas tres grupos de
centenas 123 dos grupos de decenas dos
grupos de decenas tengo dos grupos de
decenas aquí en amarillo cuatro unidades
tengo cuatro unidades así que estos son
324 bloques ahora practicamos un poco
restando de 324 lo primero que quiero
restar de 324 es restemos restamos una
decena quiero restar una decena de aquí
a una decena es
1 aquí y 00 unidades déjame escribirlo
con color azul 0 unidades así que no
estoy restando ninguna centena estoy
restando una decena la veo justo ahí
menos una decena
y no estoy restando ninguna unidad así
que cuánto me dará eso cuánto me dará
eso
bueno mis centenas no cambian no estoy
restando ninguna centena aún tengo tres
centenas así que puedo escribir esto
aquí aún tengo 3
sen
más
tenía dos decenas estoy quitando una de
ellas pero ahora tengo dos menos 1 es 2
- 1 es una decena
tenía dos escenas ahora quito una decena
quito una decena y ahora voy a tener y
ahora voy a tener más una de c
tenía dos quite una y ahora tendré una
tenía cuatro unidades y no estoy
quitando ninguna unidad por lo que aún
tengo 4
aún tengo 41 davis
cuatro unidades menos 0 unidades 4
unidades
me quedo con 314 3 centenas más una
decena más 4 unidades y si ves esto de
aquí que hacemos tenemos 324 y luego
quitamos una de las decenas así que
quitamos una de las decenas y nos
quedamos con tres centenas una decena y
cuatro unidades o tres centenas y
catorce eso fue interesante ahora
restamos una centena de 324 en lugar de
una decena así que ahora restemos ahora
restamos una centena
esto es una centena voy a restar una
centena
pero decenas
cero unidades así que restamos eso ahora
cuánto será esto tenía tres centenas
quito una de ellas ahora tengo dos
centenas tengo dos escenas no le quito
decenas y aún tengo dos decenas tenía
cuatro unidades quite cero unidades aún
tendré cuatro unidades
si ves esto de aquí cuándo será esto
déjame escribir un signo de igual
tenía tres centenas quitaré una centena
ahora tendré dos centenas
tenía dos decenas no estoy quitando
ninguna decena por lo que aún tengo dos
escenas
a 4 unidades y no estoy quitando ninguna
unidad por lo que aún tengo 4 unidades
y si piensas en eso en esta imagen de
aquí que es lo que acabo de hacer quité
un grupo de centenas quité un grupo de
centenas así que puedo quitar un grupo
de centenas de aquí
y con que me quedo me quedo con dos
centenas dos centenas dos decenas ahí
están las dos escenas y cuatro unidades
dos centenas déjame escribir a dos
centenas lo escribiré de esta manera dos
centenas dos decenas y cuatro unidades o